le moment de vérité pour l'union
européenne c'est ainsi qu emmanuel
macron qualifié la crise du cornât virus
en une du financial times le 17 avril un
appel à la solidarité entre pays membres
par le passé l'union a déjà eu du mal à
jouer collectif face à une situation
économique dégradée
l'exemple avec la crise des subprimes de
il faut une réponse mondiale au début
c'est chacun pour soi
d'autant que seuls certains pays sont
touchés c'est le cas de la
grande-bretagne en 2007 elle accorde un
prêt exceptionnel à la banque
britannique northern rock au bord de la
faillite
au fond tout cela découle de la crise
immobilière aux états unis à l'heure
actuelle le système les banques ont des
liquidités mais elle ne se prêteront pas
d'argent mutuellement comme elle le
faisait auparavant
jusque là seuls les pays touchés
agissent sur leur propre territoire
mais déjà cette période certains
économistes observent un effet domino à
venir sur toute la zone euro aucun pays
européen aujourd'hui on est en capacité
de donner des leçons aux autres en
termes de commandes spéciales type
d'événement pour autant les pays membres
ont du mal à établir une stratégie anti
crise commune en octobre 2008 nicolas
sarkozy invite les autres membres
européens du g8 allemagne italie et
grande bretagne à un mini sommet
conclusion pas de plan de sauvetage
commun chaque gouvernement agira selon
une méthode avec des moyens qui lui sont
propres mais de manière coordonnée avec
les autres états européens une monnaie
unique pour de nombreux pays un marché
commun mais les dates et les systèmes
économiques ne sont pas les mêmes
partout
l'opposant première une stratégie
commune c'est la première puissance
européenne l'allemagne la chancelière
angela merkel met son véto terme à nos
politiques nos dirigeants politiques les
états européens de stationner la
responsabilité
ceux qui ont provoqué les dégâts eux
aussi doivent assumer le seul point
d'accord c'est l'aide qu'il faut
apporter aux banques
il est alors décidé que chaque pays peut
injecter de l'argent dans ses propres
établissements bancaires en cumulé 1700
milliards d'euros il faudra
effectivement du temps pour que toutes
ces mesures une fois qu'elles seront été
voté par chacun des pays et mis en place
pour que toutes ces mesures prennent à
rêver et qu'on voit vraiment redémarrer
le système du crédit interbancaire
ce n'est qu'en 2010 qu'une solution
commune est prise alors que la dette
publique de l'union atteint 80% du pib
les tractations ont duré onze heures et
se sont achevés tard dans la nuit les
ministres des finances européens ont
finalement réussi à trouver un accord
pour enrayer la crise
il s'agit d'un fonds de secours 750
milliards d'euros avec l'argent des
états membres du budget de la commission
européenne et du fonds monétaire
international les années suivantes le
rôle de l'europe a consisté à réguler la
finance à l'échelle européenne
[Musique]